got a dive right into Vanderpump rules
is coming back so soon this season I
think might be a good one for you aye I
think so it was a good summer so I'm
hoping it's that translates into a good
season I don't think it can get worse
than last year so some way up from here
wait Rob is that who were talking about
yeah I don't know that I said that much
this II know I've never in 11 years seen
him mad so Rob he likes coffee with its
creamer I can't wait Robin one day well
we're not gonna have like two kids Rob
makes me so happy yeah did you learn
about the robbed of it all maybe don't
say somebody's name so many times think
you're gonna hear me say Adam dry like
427 times this summer but it's just you
know if I'm close with someone I talk
about them a lot I brag about them a lot
but yeah the seven-minute TV thing I
don't even want to know I'm sure someone
counted how many times I said that I'm
with a man who knows how to do
everything so embarrassing like I think
I was better about things like that but
I don't know I word vomit a lot so are
you and Adam official girlfriend no no
we're like hanging out having fun yeah I
mean we just went to Iceland together
world series Drake concert he's my best
friend he's my favorite person to hang
out with their benefits they're um
you're just gonna have to wait and see
yeah I'm not with him tonight though
what's gonna surprise us about this
season you'll see friendships of mine
like drastically change and I think
that'll be interesting I'm single for
the first time ever on this show I think
that's interesting and yeah I just I
feel really good about it so I'm like
actually excited for the season err I'm
not writing it like last year I'm like
let's do this December 3rd I'm excited
[Music]